foreign
we heard about these murals that were
being painted and on kind of
immoralizing the victims and like who
they were as individuals and I really
wanted to see them I wanted to see them
in person I wanted to see how this
healing is happening in this community
and I wanted to be here
just driving through here it's like it
literally looks like Burleson where I
grew up
our first stop
was to meet Abel Ortiz a Uvalde resident
and art Professor who came up with the
idea for the mural project this is such
a beautiful beautiful project that
you're doing thank you first of all
thank you for being here and uh and your
respect to the victims and the families
foreign I was really honored to paint
whoever I would I would wind up painting
yeah but I do have connections to
Ellie's family the mirror that I painted
and it's right around the corner here
[Music]
oh my gosh
this is Ellie oh my gosh she was robust
full of life and every day was was
special for her that is so beautiful oh
my God this is thank you so H Miller is
going to tell you their story
it's a baseball card design because she
won the championship the Saturday before
yeah that's why I put champion on her
I love that
it's our response to that tragedy that
we're going to be defined by and the
murals provide that positive path
towards that redefinition of our
community and us as individuals
and what a beautiful way for these
family members to get to come and see
them like this yes ah in person they're
massive yes they have to be Monumental
yeah because of pain is monuments yeah
wow I can't imagine
[Music]
next Abel and I went to meet Monica
Maldonado the founder of the art-based
non-profit Mas kotora who worked
tirelessly organizing this massive
project so you found a bunch of Hispanic
artists right Latin artists right
knowing that you've all used upwards of
82 percent Hispanic it definitely was
important for me that the artist be
Latino
my name is Dino Ortega and I'm here
painting murals for you about the family
members were out here yesterday helping
me paint I was teaching them how to
paint if you help me paint a mural
you're going to sign it and that's what
they did it right there I hope they have
a positive memory out of such a tragic
circumstance
sometimes you can't express with words
what you can with visuals and you
connect the dots in a sense you build
the life of the child as you explore
across the whole mural
this is Uzziah there was just a very
caring and compassionate kid that really
just wanted to make the world a better
place and there's a story about him
where he's got this cookie and one of
his classmates asked him for a piece of
it and he takes it and he crumbles it up
and he shares it with the rest of his
class
and when I heard that story I knew
immediately that rich would have to
paint him because rich is the same way
ah is this Layla this is Layla Layla
would outrace all the boys
yeah she won every race
so this is Lexi Rubio and Lexi's mural
was painted by Reuben Esquivel and
Carmen Rangel one of the things you're
gonna notice on the mural are the
butterflies so the butterflies symbolize
all her siblings
the second day I believe it was the
second day that the artist was working
on it
a butterfly showed up right and it
landed right on his hand as he was
painting butter he was painting
butterflies
Eliana Torres beautiful she actually was
up to be on the All-Star team and that
day that this happened she would have
found out that she had made the All-Star
team
Nevaeh Bravo was painted by Britt
Johnson
the most important thing is that the
mural includes her art so the birds the
rose the heart and the I love you are
actually replications of her work
so this is my day and this was designed
by Anna Hernandez one of the things that
Maite was known for were the green
Converse and she also wanted to be a
marine biologist
Emery this medal was given to her by the
Girl Scouts Anne-Marie dialed 9-1-1
while she was in the classroom
trying to save her friends
wow
Eva Mireles what is really inspiring
about her aside the fact that she was a
teacher her favorite thing was going to
the mountains and hiking the artist that
painted this Sandra Gonzalez and
designed it she's also art teacher
Irma was a teacher that was just really
loved by so many people and we would
hear time and time again like she was my
teacher and Joe worked at the HEB he
worked at the local HEB
so some of the really special things on
this is the 25 they were about a month
away from celebrating their 25th
anniversary
this is a blank canvas and our plan is
to put all the names here we will
continue efforts of fundraising through
the GoFundMe and this is probably money
to preserve as well yeah so we'll using
the money to preserve well we actually
heard that y'all were needing more funds
so we wanted to help y'all so we're
going to give you all ten thousand
dollars just to help out oh my just to
help out like it's the least we can do
it's so important for people to come see
this it's going to basically complete
the project for us because we're
struggling with the funds here at the
end and so that's going to really really
uh you know how happy I am right now
thank you so much
you got you guys are the Angels thank
you so much you're such a it's such a an
amazingly cool thing to do in such a
horrific
in a situation
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
devastating what has happened but to
also like see these murals and
experience what they were like
living like it's life and
and that's how you wanna
well that's how I would what
my child
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]